Right now, Taiwan is practicing for war.
The island just finished its largest
military exercises in history.
22,000 people preparing for a potential
Chinese invasion. And
here's the wild part.
This entire crisis centers on a
historical claim that China has
controlled Taiwan since ancient times.
But when I started digging into what
historians actually say about this,
well, let's just say the story is a lot
more complicated than
either side wants you to believe.
Beijing points to four main historical
periods as evidence
they've always controlled Taiwan.
Ancient expeditions from 230,
Sui dynasty contact in the 1600s,
Yuan dynasty administration in the 1290s,
and Qing dynasty rule from 1683 to 1895.
So I spent weeks reading academic papers
and checking sources.
What I found is in the simple story of
propaganda versus facts.
It's something much more interesting.
Let me walk you through what
scholars actually agree on,
what they're still debating, and why it
matters for understanding today's crisis.
So China says that in 230, Chinese texts
describe expeditions to
an island called Yizhou,
which they identify as Taiwan.
Now, here's what we can actually verify.
The primary source is Chenshu's Record of
the Three Kingdoms, written around 290.
It describes expeditions by Sun Quan that
brought back thousands of people
from this mysterious island.
But here's where it gets interesting.
According to the Cambridge history of
China, and I'm quoting here,
some scholars have identified this island
as Taiwan, while others do not.
We're talking about events from 1800
years ago, described in
texts written decades later,
using geographic terms that ancient
Chinese applied pretty
loosely to various islands.
Even if these
expeditions did reach Taiwan,
historians agree that nothing permanent
came of these contexts.
No administration, no
lasting presence, no follow-up.
So, bottom line, there might have been
early Chinese contact with Taiwan,
but the identification is disputed and
the impact was minimal.
Think of it like Vikings reaching North
America centuries before Columbus.
Interesting historically?
Absolutely.
But not really
establishing territorial control.
Next up, Beijing argues the Siyu
dynasties sent three successful
expeditions to Liu Qiu
in 607, 608 and 610.
But here's the problem.
Nobody's quite sure what
Liu Qiu actually refers to.
According to scholar Cheng
Biu, and I'm quoting again,
some scholars believe that the record of
Liu Qiu referred to the
Liu Qiu island near Taiwan.
While some say it was a reference to what
are now the Liu Qiu islands,
and others suggest it was a general term
referring to islands in the East China
Sea and nearby waters.
Here's a fascinating detail though.
Zhu Kuan, the leader of the first Sui
expeditions to Liu Qiu,
originally wrote a name with the
characters meaning "flowing dragon".
Because the shape of the island reminded
him of a dragon floating on the sea.
While Okinawa is a long and thin island
that later commentators also
associated with the dragon,
Taiwan is an oval-shaped
island rather than dragon-shaped.
So here's where we land.
The Siyu expeditions definitely happened,
but we can't even be
sure where they went,
let alone whether they
established any lasting control.
Now the third piece of evidence is where
things get really interesting.
Beijing says the Yuan dynasty established
administrative control in the 1290s.
But when you dig into the records, well
this is actually kind of
embarrassing for territorial
claims. In 1292 Kublai Khan sent
officials to the Ryukyu
kingdom to demand its loyalty.
But plot twist, the officials ended up in
Taiwan and must have took it for Ryukyu.
Think about that for a moment. These
weren't explorers discovering new lands,
they were officials who got completely
lost trying to reach a
different island entirely.
When they arrived in Taiwan they couldn't
communicate with the indigenous people.
After three soldiers were killed the
delegation immediately retreated.
As Taiwanese scholar Professor Leifu Xun
points out, this actually
demonstrates that Taiwan and
China were separate entities. How can
getting lost landing in the
wrong place, losing soldiers and
immediately fleeing constitute evidence
of territorial control?
They tried again in 1297,
but once again no lasting administrative
presence was established.
Now we get to Beijing's strongest
historical argument,
the Qing dynasty period.
And honestly this one is genuinely
complex. In 1683 Qing
forces defeated the Ming loyalist
Tseng regime and annexed Taiwan for 212
years. For 212 years until
1895 there was a real Chinese
administrative control over parts of
Taiwan. But, and this is a
big but, even this period
wasn't what modern territorial claims
suggest. M.I. Tseng, one of
the world's leading Taiwan
historians, puts it perfectly. Taiwan was
terra incognita for the
better part of Chinese history.
Even during the Qing period, until 300
years ago, the Chinese
considered Taiwan a land beyond
the seas, a ball of mud inhabited by
naked and tattooed savages.
Here's what the evidence shows.
The Qing established formal boundary
systems with stone markers
separating hunt settler areas
from indigenous territories. This was
gradual expansion over
centuries, not immediate
island-wide control. And here's a
revealing moment from 1874. When Japan
invaded southern Taiwan,
the Qing had to pay indemnity for
Japanese withdrawal,
because Japan argued these areas
weren't under effective Chinese control.
If the Qing really
controlled all of Taiwan,
why couldn't they defend it without
paying Japan to leave? The story ends in
1895 when, after losing
the first Sino-Japanese war, the Qing
ceded Taiwan to Japan in
the Treaty of Shimonoseki .
Taiwan then spent 50 years in their
comprehensive Japanese administration.
Now here's what gets lost in modern
political arguments. By the
end of the Qing rule in 1895,
Taiwan's ethnic Han population had
increased by over 2 million. Real
communities, real families,
real economic and cultural development
happened during the Qing period.
But here's the crucial point. The
People's Republic of
China, the government making
territorial claims today, was established
in 1949. It has never
controlled Taiwan for even a
single day. Here's what actually happened
after World War II.
Taiwan was transferred to the
Republic of China. When the Chinese Civil
War ended in 1949, the
ROC government relocated
to Taiwan while the PRC took control of
mainland China. We've had
two separate governments ever
since. So where does this leave us?
Here's what historians
across the political spectrum
actually agree on. Indigenous
Austro-Asian peoples inhabited Taiwan for
thousands of years before any
Chinese contact. Early Chinese contacts
were brief and didn't
establish lasting control.
Yuan dynasty
expeditions failed completely.
The Qing dynasty exercised real but
geographically limited
control for over two centuries.
Japanese period involved comprehensive
island-wide administration.
Post-1949, the vision created genuinely
separate political systems.
And here's what they're still
debating. Whether ancient expeditions
actually reached Taiwan. How
to interpret the extent and
significance of King control. Legal
implications of World War
II territorial transfers.
When you examine the historical evidence
objectively, you don't
find a simple story of
"Taiwan has always been Chinese" or
"Taiwan was never Chinese". You find
something more complex.
An island with indigenous peoples.
Gradual Chinese settlement
during one particular dynasty.
Comprehensive Japanese modernization. And
then post-war division
that continues today.
The current crisis isn't really about
ancient history. It's about
how modern governments use
selective historical narratives to
justify contemporary
political goals. Understanding
Taiwan's real history helps us see beyond
the political talking
points. Whether you support
unification, independence or maintaining
the status quo. The
historical record shows that Taiwan's
relationship with China has been much
more complicated,
contested and recent than either
side usually admits. The next time you
hear claims about ancient
territorial rights, remember,
good history is messy, complicated and
full of uncertainty.
It's the simple, confident,
historical claims you should probably
question. What do you think?
Let me know in the comments
and don't forget to subscribe for more
fact-checking on the claims
driving today's headlines.